taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them hey taste buddies welcome to
taste buds
there he is how you doing man good you
showed up rocking my merch I love it I'm
wearing your merch you're wearing your
merch short of I made this one before
those I made this one just at this place
in Atlanta that I always go to it's
called bang on
oh I know bang on watching and we know
that you are I think it's in Little Five
Points right yeah yeah I know that place
I made no less than 20 shirts there was
on the show we can't make we can't wear
stuff we don't have the rights to so I
started just making my own shirts oh on
the Joker show yeah yeah the uh I appeal
by the way to all my stand-up comedy
friends all my friends with bands are
all my friends have shirts send them to
me I'll wear them on the show oh great
yeah I love that yeah I love uh I every
time I go to Atlanta to visit my friend
Jim and Jess uh they I always go to Five
Points criminal record is always a huge
stop for me always I love that place uh
and bang On's great some great bars and
five years
in that neighborhood for the Joker movie
that's interesting I I recorded my album
you will die at Star Bar there oh oh no
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I lived
there six weeks you know and uh we
filmed that was our set to be stationed
there we satellite it everywhere but
that was one of the main hubs and we
filmed a lot of scenes there
why did you guys Hub in in the South
because it was it was the budget wise
that was where we had to shoot well yeah
for a lot of reasons one primarily
budget and then two
according to the creative we wrote we
had to look up where we could film these
things like we needed a motorcycle rally
we needed this we needed that and so we
kind of like started there and then like
we kind of like you know it was a good
Central Point okay yeah all right nice
man all right stuff today I got stuff I
got stuff too well I got fan stuff let
me let me do this first okay
because I don't want to forget shout
outs to the fans
um there's no pick well hold on let me
see who sent this this is displayed
currently in the bar
okay Joey Rose's not because I'm trying
to cop something made for us but because
it's a decoration
and I wanted it to be properly seen by
people okay uh
so so Justin the pumpkin nerd he goes by
uh wrote us a letter it's time to get
spooky it's time to get spooky it's time
to get spooky hey taste buddies I hope
you enjoyed this pumpkin as much as I
enjoyed the pot I just wanted to say
thanks for the hours of entertainment
you provide thank you Justin and then he
makes these kinds of pumpkins oh cool we
got a shot of this and he made us a
taste buds one he made us one with that
logo carved into it and it arrived like
not everybody sends everything to cut
pumpkin it's a it's fake it's like a
foam oh it's like reusable yeah like
it's a permanent you can have this for
the rest of our lives you left that part
out yeah so at what point does the
pumpkin become a Jack-o-Lantern is the
jack-o-lantern indicative of it being
cut or is it jack-o-lantern indicative
of a flame or is it Jacqueline
indicative of only a face not a design a
face and or a flame I believe the face
there's no flame in it but it has a face
on its cut is it a Jack-o-Lantern I
believe so I believe the face I believe
they were you I think it's one of those
things they were carved the ward off
Spirits or some okay
um anyway the one in the bar I can bring
it in but but I was like I it came to
the bar and I put it right into the
window because I was like I love it babe
I was like I want people to be able to
see this yeah but this gives me an idea
we should have a no pressure wide
jack-o-lantern contest oh yeah and the
fans can vote on the best one and we'll
do like between us and we'll do like a
prize I love that
like we'll get five pumpkins or
whoever's here three pumpkins because
before we'll go in there we'll take like
a half hour we'll cut them up oh we do
it yeah bro Oh I thought you meant like
the fans do yeah I'm into that oh I've
never carved one since I was a kid with
my Dad yeah me neither it seems I
painted one recently okay uh about three
four years ago during the Pandy It seems
impossible it seems impossible you know
who's really looking at Chris Johnston
he's already like an artist and like he
used to do graffiti and he does Ireland
and he buys his like razor sharp knife
and he can do that and I was like I'm
mind-blowing I can't do that
um my nieces and I made my mind a Steve
zizu pumpkin so follow Justin on all
socials ask the pumpkin nerd and then
this is even crazier now I don't know if
if he actually sent this meter
uh
there's a three-page letter here all
right but
I should have read this I think I just
pulled my shoulder in a way that hurts
really bad
like my collarbone area shoulder
like something feels pulled in there up
in that
uh
what are you gonna do all right this kid
made this meter
see it m-e-t-e-r yeah
here I'll hold it up so you can maybe
like the Funky Meters go in on the meter
okay
uh
the dial pointing at 10 in the oh boy I
should have read this before I don't
know it's somehow a meter with software
that indicates how the votes work what
uh you gotta come prepared for this bro
I know I didn't I didn't know it was
just involved when I opened it where's
the meter
I don't know I don't know if he sent the
meter I have a hard drive and a letter
that was put into and you're opening
this you're opening a three-page letter
and a hard drive with no meter for the
first time and you want to discuss right
now kid's name can we
different address to mail things besides
my bar because things are showing up
there along with shipments
you got a jack-o'-lantern I know but
it's real hard to keep track of this
stuff yeah but you know you should have
vetted this this is we're live on the
air babe yeah you want me to skim it
over here and see yeah yeah thank you
maybe throw that throw that uh here's
your hard drive won't you maybe that has
like maybe that has access right fair
enough yeah you never know what's in
that
the kid it doesn't even seem to be
signed by a name or anything I think he
did send the meter I think it's in the
closet at my bar well I'm just worried
have you seen what's happening at the
MGM casinos they're all shut down
nationwide why what happened hackers
took over all the casino machines and
are holding him hostage oh my God wait
how could I not have heard about that it
happened overnight is it all over the
news today yeah that's massive news not
as big as Aaron Rodgers but it's up
there I know wait what happened with
Aaron Rodgers he okay
what he died he didn't die his dreams of
this season died didn't he did wait I
didn't know so I was I was it just broke
like an hour ago he's out half of the
season oh he's like injured yeah like
the first I mean okay I was being silly
I love the guy yeah yeah but I just mean
it's terrible it's just something I
thought you meant like he did something
bad I was like oh no actually was busy
last night and I did not see the game
and I'm walking out of my place and I
passed someone I knew and they were like
hear about Rogers and I was like what
they're like out for the season fourth
play of the game I was like You Gotta Be
You gotta be kidding oh my God like he's
come to Jets man the goddamn Jets he's
coming here after a full 10 years in
Green Bay to come over here and try to
do some damage in the last two years
here everybody was so excited let me
tell you something around this it took
months and months for him to sign with a
team everybody was following him we
didn't know if we were going to get him
we didn't know we I'm a I'm a Steelers
fan but I mean I'm a New York guy so
they get him fourth place of the game
dude what happened think about him
staying in shape in the off season
coming here knowing he has a role to
play signing this contract extending you
know his his career past Green Bay and
you come in on on on Monday Night
Football national game in week one and I
think he tore his Achilles I think in
the fourth play oh Jesus dude that sucks
man we uh we're sorry about that buddy
if you're watching look at the way his
foot's bed
uh
that sucks Aaron Rodgers is a cool dude
he we we've spoken here and there in the
past by chance
so so he's he's out for the season but
then he'll be back next season yeah but
I mean he's up for a full year I think
it was a one-year contract no oh oh oh
the country one does he still get paid
I think so
there's only one here in the contract
am I wrong that that sounds like a good
deal you don't have to you don't have to
pay you just get play you just get paid
good deal to us I mean I would assign
the contract and literally got my my
literally my larynx ripped out and been
like okay it's all good just every I
would have been like I I got the money
it's every cop movie
I never understand like the cop will go
Rogue and they don't get in trouble and
then the sergeant will go spends him
with suspension two weeks with pay get
out of here and the guy's like how dare
you I'm like yeah what are you talking
about he's like get out of here cool off
yeah yeah and then what do they do they
take it into their own hands and they
stay on the case and they sneak yeah you
know they do that yeah they don't listen
to anybody yeah take the vacay take the
vacation they're like they then they go
then they go Rogue again
okay
all right how bad is that give me a
little set the scene for me a little bit
did you do something terrible I'm not
whiffing around I want to know my anger
level it's not my case and I'm sniffing
around and places I shouldn't be right
now yeah and I'm gonna compromise the
case and the mayor's on your ass okay
gotcha all right yeah somebody had to be
on my ass yeah yeah ready sit down
DeRosa yeah it has come to my attention
that you're snooping around in the
Sullivan cases yeah yeah no well okay
somebody's got to do it and there's
certainly any more even down my ass
right now you cannot go beyond your
jurisdiction listen to me by
jurisdiction copter Rosa but you can't
go Rogue there are no cops in this
Precinct anymore I'm the last one I'll
Snoop in whatever case I want to Snoop
on I'm gonna need your badge and gun two
weeks paid you know what give me three
[Laughter]
but on other people's cases to get
suspension with me
so true
dude anything you do you get in trouble
I know it's crazy you know you took you
you went somewhere on lunch you know I
don't know what the hell but I would do
the same thing it's true the uh uh so
someone's always chewing the the
Lieutenant's ass out though and then he
in turn had to chew the other asses out
yeah it's the same sound you're
breathing down my neck they're chewing
on my ass and it's always City Hall it's
always big yeah it's shitty mayor or
city hall or you know I got them coming
down on me you know I used to like the
uh this is not my locker I don't know
who's locking that is sketched at uh no
sir it's not my portion was you in
ghetto right blind cops yeah that was
very funny yeah one night I I looked up
all like the tenderloin sketches because
those are 20 something years old I love
the you know the time machine one right
yeah that's everybody's fave uh I I
think right I mean it's the one I've
heard discussed most because we won uh
we want to we on we want NBC on show on
NBC Battle of the best sketch troops
okay and that one okay won us a hundred
grand all right well then yeah it never
aired but they had to pay us
see same thing same thing yeah yeah the
uh the uh I I that's my favorite of the
sketches so uh and I like a lot of them
but but so what you're talking about my
favorite is called time thugs no not
time thugs oh which one Oh you mean when
I come back
when you come when you go back and have
sex with Murray's son yeah I was like
that's a Craig Murray incident yeah I
was like that one on NBC that's crazy
the one you're talking about which is
Bobby Kelly loves it he always sings it
to me because I sing so yeah the one
Bobby the one you're talking about is so
uh Murray builds a time machine and he
goes back in time and he comes back and
he tells me that in the future I have a
daughter and he slips he slept with her
and he's doing it as Revenge because
you're talking oh no he's doing as
Revenge because I ate his mugugai pan
leftovers that's right that's right yeah
and he went real far the other direction
yeah yeah and I was like I don't have a
daughter he's like no you you do in the
future and I need to slept with her and
then I get incensed and I run into his
time machine hit a bunch of buttons and
I go back and when I come back I had to
spend six months in the past I come back
a few moments later and I told him that
he has he got he had a son yeah he goes
I I go why I got you back he goes I
don't have a daughter I go but you do
have a son and I you son
I said I didn't I'd even just I didn't
even just F them I got into a
relationship with and made him fall in
love with me and I broke his heart after
six months and then we go back and we
show the photo yeah it's so funny you're
dancing and singing everybody's looking
it's so funny so I got a hankering to
watch that one night so I watched it and
then I was like I went down the rabbit
hole was watching other steps and I
sketches I'd never seen blind cops but I
really enjoyed blind oh thanks man
thanks yeah yeah it's so it's old I mean
it's when we just were like the
sensibility of change but I appreciate
that you felt like it held up a little
sure yeah fan is brilliant by the way
this is a very interesting device here
yeah no it's like real science yeah it's
real science he's like it definitely
seems to be an inventor and engineer is
his name on it though I don't see his
name Andrew Solano Andrew Solano
s-o-l-a-n-o so we he has a device that
you input it's a meter I don't know
where the meter is he might have sent
the meter to the bar all I was given
from one of my bartenders was that
envelope with the hard drive but the I
the hard drive is a bunch of programs he
taught together
uh Demeter must be somewhere in the bar
it does spend two paragraphs convincing
us it's safe to use the hard drive on
your computer okay
um you know I don't know but so the
meter will sit on the table here and it
won't indicate who's exactly winning but
that one party is
winning by 25 or 40 percent
because it's pulling votes from it's
tied Twitter of Twitter vote no it's a
it's like a little computer it's
brilliant so so without knowing we'll
see a meter swaying in someone's
Direction but I have no idea for which
one well I'll know I'll just wouldn't
you'll know but it's a tease but it's
it's literally directly reading the
actual real-time Twitter polls yeah
apparently how's that even possible
you want me to call the bar and say is
the meter there
well what will happen then
well I'll say put it aside well why
don't you do that off you know I don't
know I thought maybe the people like see
behind see it all in action oh yeah but
people like it behind the curve there
and then they're gonna look and say yes
or no they're gonna hang up no I'm gonna
say why don't you go look for the meter
yeah and let me know if it's there if
you could I'd appreciate it
folks let's talk mint mobile you you
know signing your life away to a big
wireless provider is kind of like being
trapped on a roller coaster from hell so
it looks fun at first and then they
probably throw in a free phone maybe
they offer you a back massage whatever
they're offering perks all over the
place but the next thing you know you
can't get off the ride month after month
it's an insane bill that you don't want
to foot and you got a lot of unexpected
unwanted unwelcome Thrills like overages
and surprise fees and stuff like that
anyway look mint Mobile's here to help
for a limited time Wireless plans for
mint mobile or just 15 bucks a month
that's unlimited talk text and data for
15 bucks a month that's like that's a
crazy price that's a that's a big
savings versus what we usually pay yeah
I want to say what I pay I pay like like
eight times that yeah I like this
service quite a bit I've used it I've
enjoyed it uh and some people close to
me in my life have started to use it
because of uh our relation to it through
this show and uh it's just a great look
it's kind of a hard thing to to over
sell because it says it all right there
it's because it's 15 bucks a month for
unlimited talk decks pretty much I mean
you know to get you a new Unlimited
Wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mintmobile.com tastebuds
that's mintmobile.com taste buds cut
your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
at mintmobile.com taste buds butcher box
yes baby folks butcher box we love
butcher box and let me talk to you about
the uniqueness of the butcher box deal
uh I make meals with butcher box all the
time why because I love meat and I
personally love the steaks more than
anything else but uh I really really
love that butcherbox is providing high
quality Meat and seafood delivered
straight to my door the seafood also I'm
very much a big fan of
um and it's coming right to my door it's
high quality and it's affordable uh it
it's it's the convenience factor the the
cost the taste everything it can't be
always have they always have free
shipping
um it's a delivery service goes right to
your door I think you can curate they
curate them or you could create your own
you could pause whenever you want I I
I've been using this since day one since
and I love it
um and as I said at the beginning the
uniqueness of the butcher box deal why
is it unique because it's a deal that I
don't often see anywhere else I don't
see a deal this good anywhere else
especially when it comes to a product
like Quality Meat and meats are a thing
that are getting real pricey at the
stores right and butcher box is giving
us a special deal sign up today at
butcherbox.com Taste Buds and use code
taste buds to get 20 off your first
order that's butcherbox.com taste buds
and use our code taste buds to claim
this deal folks Joe DeRosa here I got
dates coming up on the road where am I
going well next stop is Toronto Ontario
for the JFL Festival I'm going to be
doing my new hour I Never Promised You a
Rose Garden write that in there oh it's
going to be a good time also going to be
doing that same new hour in Philadelphia
PA on November 11th in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania on November 17th November
18th in Buffalo New York November 30th
in Denver Colorado December 1st in
Phoenix Arizona and in Salt Lake City
Utah on December 3rd but I've got some
other cool shows on the books too on
October 28th here in New York City at
Arlene's grocery my band salsa windfall
doing the first show we've done live in
25 years the events called Festival it's
us it's esoteric and 7-0 from Czarface
we're doing we'll see you in hell live
the stumble bums are coming through we
got all kinds of surprises and fun
things happening an 80s dance party
going on after all the performers get
off stage that night it's going to be a
great time followed by an after party at
Joey roses also just announced as part
of the New York Comedy Festival I am
doing a show at KGB bar November 9th
also here in New York City called
selected readings I'm going to be
reading entries for my new audiobook The
Penthouse papers along with some other
pieces I've written and had published
and maybe some unreleased writings and
stuff not stand up but a funny show
where I get to read to you guys in the
Cozy confines of the KGB bar Anyway come
check all that out and as always
whether it's after that show at Arlene's
or another time come check out Joey
roses we're open seven days a week 11 30
a.m each day drinks and affordable
sandwiches deliciousness fun good times
people come on down maybe You See Me
Maybe you see pimp we're there all the
time check it out Joey Rose's tickets
for that event and all the Live Events I
have set are available at joederrosa.com
again jodarosa.com for Ticket links show
info whatever it is all right everybody
I am taping my stand-up comedy special
live at the Vic Theater in Chicago on
Saturday December 2nd tickets are on
sale right now I've been talking about
this thing for months and months and
dreaming about it for years and years
you can get tickets right now at
salvolcanocomedy.com tickets are going
to go fast I hope to see you guys and I
want to do one thing for you because you
supported me uh my whole career I'm
going to pick one person out of everyone
that attends these shows and give you a
plus one and I'm going to fly you to New
York put you up in a hotel and take you
on the set of Impractical Jokers
there'll be one winner that can bring a
plus one all you got to do is be there
and you are eligible to win so December
2nd I hope to see you guys there take it
to salvocano comedy.com right now I'm
I'm honestly dying to know what happened
to Sally seems frustrated coming in oh
wait something happened yeah well we've
got okay hold on we've got it we've got
battles we're doing the fry tourney but
then also too happy fry 20 part one yeah
yeah lightning round of fries today and
four fries on another wrap yeah and then
the two winners will face each other in
the ultimate okay I love that yeah so
okay so we got we got we got some behind
the scenes stuff that you want to play
but we could actually play that on the
next episode when the guests are here
because it pertains to the guests no but
they're not doing it no no no no this is
I think it was more for the fry but okay
then okay so we're gonna play some
voicemails okay okay so and then but
then you all you want to do that now or
do you want to do your why you're hot
coming in hot do hot and then we'll go
that could lead right into the bag okay
got it I might need you to uh be no no
no BS to Rosa today for me again I might
need you to get me a refund
really yeah wow for what okay I love it
so this morning I'm gonna come in okay
call an Uber okay it says four minutes I
had to be here in time for a zoom
consultation yeah that was expensive
that I missed okay a consultation for
what can I ask that's that's you know
that okay okay so nothing bad or
anything uh so so I call them four
minutes I hit send 4.96 Stars so that's
pretty high of a rating it's a damn
higher guys done over 90. I looked him
up five and a half years he's done over
19 000 trips okay so you think well this
can't get any better than that this guy
is a seasoned professional
496 after 19 000 and change trips over
five years this guy doesn't play games
right it's a lot yeah four minutes I hit
enter huh two minutes three minutes I'm
seeing he's not moving four minutes it's
not moving five minutes six minutes he's
where he is when I call him so after six
minutes I message him I said hey I
noticed in the app that you haven't
moved
since I ordered you is everything okay
should I cancel and call someone else he
writes no I'm on the way
I said okay I close my app I open it
again I sign off Wi-Fi I open it again
I'm like maybe my phone's Frozen
seven minutes eight minutes nine minutes
ten minutes he's in the same exact spot
so I wrote hey
are you how far away are you
um because on my app you still haven't
moved and I I just need to know if I
should get someone else
he writes I don't know why it's doing
that I'm one minute away okay
and the whole time I zoom in on the map
and it looks like
he is at a Dunkin Donuts
[Music]
okay
please I hope he's out of doctor but I
can't please let it be at a Dunkin
Donuts right
then after he says I'll be there in one
minute like a minute after that his car
starts to move so I'm like all right so
he's he wasn't moving now he is I see
him miss my well he takes like three
four minutes to get to where he the
block he has to turn on I see him miss
it when you miss it you have to go all
the way down all the way around another
block all the way back and it's going to
delay you even further size now he does
that now this guy is night it's 19
minutes I'm waiting for him and the
whole time he's stringing me along so I
didn't want to cancel and then go off a
bit yeah right now yeah and the next guy
does it to me and I was like should I
should I jump in my own car but then I
didn't want to waste time parking
because I had to be here so he finally
gets to me it's he's not he's it says
four minutes he takes 19. I sit in the
car and I go hey how you doing man good
good was everything okay I said I I it
said four minutes you know it's been 19
minutes and he goes oh yeah man made the
wrong turn
and I go oh because I saw him make that
wrong turn right but that only
sacrificed I would say six three four
minutes okay four minutes
she's like oh yeah I saw that and you
had to go all the way up and all the way
around because you missed that turn he
goes yeah all right all right no problem
man no problem I said that that happens
and I lean back
and in his cup holder it's a piping hot
fresh large Dunkin Donut coffee I mean
it's it's okay it's Curb Your Enthusiasm
so you gotta it's this is yeah this is
uh yeah yeah
so I go I couldn't help but notice
how about this
that's exactly Larry so here's this son
of a right see the Duncan in this
thing yeah here he is right well that's
what I zoomed in
I zoomed in and I he accepted my order
at 10 45 a.m and he ordered that at
10 48 and 30 seconds what why'd you say
something I took a picture of it I
zoomed in and then then after like one
minute we're driving I go oh I see what
it is Duncan
I said it just like that I go I see what
it is Duncan and he doesn't say nothing
I go because you were stopped at a
Duncan uh-huh I said so you were at the
Dunkin yeah I said it like that he
doesn't say anything drive the rest away
in silence
you don't you don't go sir I'm talking
to you no because here's the thing
nothing's coming out of me chastising
him in that moment oh yes I disagree
because he a great feeling inside of you
is coming out
but he he this is why I don't like the
system he can rate me bad for having a a
very very good gripe with him and I
don't want to affect my you
understand what I'm saying so I don't
want to affect my rating so I was like
let me buy my lip because when I get out
of here
I'm gonna be on with the suits on the
app I'm gonna be on there I'm gonna get
in a full refund well buddy here's the
tough part with Uber they make it really
hard there is no phone call you're
saying this to me yeah oh boy Uber is a
real tough one dude I had an Uber driver
once claim that I hit him
now look what I had an Uber driver who
was who was batshit I was in San
Francisco
uh I'll never forget I was with uh uh
what's his name from uh oh God I'm
buddies with the guy the guy from uh
Undateable
Mick Jagger no no the kid that starred
in uh Undateable uh I can't believe I'm
blanking on his name Ron funches no he
no no no
um Brent Moore yeah I kept want to say
bread Ernst Brett Morin
I don't remember if he was with me in
the Uber or not or if I was going to
meet him at a bar but he was at Cobbs
and I was at the punch line and we were
going to go out drinking and I got an
Uber and I brought my oh that's what it
was I brought the feature Act and the
host with me okay yo guys come with me
we're gonna go drink
and we got into the Uber at the hotel
and this guy was like nuts
and he was like yeah screaming and
singing and like to a point where I
had to be like hey buddy dude you gotta
you gotta calm down bro like are you
good was it the early days of uber
early early
[Music]
not now let's put it that way you know
what I mean it was pre well it was
pre-covered
yeah but I mean it was still Uber was
established okay you know Lyft had come
out like all that and
the guy was being crazy to the point
where I had to be like bro are you cool
because you seem like you're up
right now yeah and he was flying in a
way where not drunk like it was like
Angel Dusty or something
and uh
he kind of got like a little bit of an
attitude and then he dropped us off and
then they called me the devil a woman
called me and she's like this is Uber
and I was like okay and she goes uh
you've been reported there there's an
incident report with your name and I go
what and she she tells me and she goes
did you physically assault a driver and
they go and I go what are you talking
about and I go miss this guy is a
batshit crazy I told the whole story and
she goes she goes okay we we had a
feeling
and I don't think that anything will
come of this but we had to hear what
your side of it was and I go I've got
witnesses and she goes no I don't think
we'll need that and it went away I
wonder why they had a feeling I wonder
what he wrote or what he said uh exactly
but and it went away and they called me
they're like everything's fine don't
worry about it yeah
um but my point is is like even in a
scenario that extreme I had to like wait
for them to call me it was hard to get
in touch with a pain in the ass I've
used them a lot like whatever the
diamond like I I spend all eyes so I
feel like they should accommodate me so
then and then there was an accident
and I got all you can do is 30 minutes
missed my full consultation and I said
oh when we when we finally passed the
fire truck for the accident I go ah I go
if you didn't stop at Duncan oh she did
say something else I just said it like
under my bed I was like we passed it I
just went if we didn't stop at Duncan
but I didn't want to give me him to give
me a bad thing but I'm gonna go in here
right now I've had enough I've had guys
throw me out of the car I'm giving him a
one I bet guys busting my money back and
I took screenshots everything you can do
a request through the app but that's
like all you can do there's like no
higher level there was a higher level
because if this doesn't happen with
taking it to the taste buds All Right
audience okay well then that's fine yeah
yeah so please hear The Throne out of
the car story oh dude throwing out once
too uh I had any crazy Uber stores I had
a cab driver once
he uh he just drove past like my it was
like wild like how wrong he got the
route
and I go dude you got to stop the meter
you got to stop the meter dude you're
driving like a mile out of the way right
now you got to stop the meter because in
New York Yellow Cab that's a lot of
extra money right and he wouldn't stop
it and he's going he's going and we stop
at a red light and he turns and he goes
he goes hey buddy you don't make
mistakes you don't make mistakes I can't
make a mistake you're gonna do this to
me and I go oh yeah oh yeah you calling
this a mistake you don't want to stop
demeanor and I go you want to me
here's me you and I got out of
the cab with the meter was still running
the guy followed me
there you go got out of scab and he was
yelling at me and I was just going
you you me first I bet you
stopped the meeting now
and people were looking and I was
like I actually got nervous for a second
that was gonna end up like on Tick Tock
and uh but yeah but uh yeah dude I've
gotten out I've had guys pull over and
go get get out of my get out of my car
because I can't let it go dude if a guy
messes with me like that it makes me
crazy just remind me of another one so
first time I haven't even heard the word
Uber I was leaving the Javits Center for
filming and they put me in one to get me
home and like it's this new thing Uber
or whatever I got in this SUV like an
Escalade or some big one and the guy
literally was swerving the whole way
home he lowered the window and was like
Hey head out the window I was like this
guy is so drunk he can't even stay in a
lane but I didn't know what it was I
didn't know you could report them I
didn't know anything I I just was like
because someone else called it for me
right and I was like holy that guy
was drunk so I I told them but anyway
you know there another time we get in
the car with three three people I forget
where we were this guy pulls up and
there's three of us it's a small compact
car so two of us get in the back one of
us go to get in the front he goes no no
no no no back right and we're like uh
okay well it's just three of us um so
it's it's tight back there can you
because he had stuff in the front he's
like I ain't moving my stuff get in the
back and and we're like you know this is
supposed to be a four pass we're only
three guys so you know you know my you
know so we just got in the car in the
back like this and I go I go
hey man I was like you're not trying to
like you know whatever I was like but
you know we just we just type back here
and right and and he literally goes this
is my car I tell you what to do you
don't tell us what to do right don't
tell me what to do but he was cursing
and and I forgot what we said he
just slammed the car through Empire goes
yeah and I was like get out yeah I was
like dude and now we were reporting him
but anyway I had a guy in Columbus I was
going to my show from the hotel yeah
and it was raining too so like you I had
to take it over yeah walking was not an
option I was going to be soaked yeah I
was I was really cutting it close too
yeah so I like to really roll in and
walk right on like I don't like to sit
there at all I get annoyed sitting there
and uh and uh
I I the guy it was one of those hotels
where the uh the the pickup spots
upstairs they got to go up like a ramp
above a parking garage
I'm standing out there I'm standing same
thing standing up there standing up
there saying the guy's there I'm like
dude where are you he's like I'm here
I'm like
I don't see you man I'm outside I don't
see you
standing there standing there calm again
I'm here where are you he goes yeah man
I'm down on the street and I go okay
that's great I'm gonna need you to come
up the ramp to where the pickup area is
he goes well I'm down on the street and
I go yeah I understand I ordered the car
to the pickup area so I'm gonna need you
to come up to the pickup area he goes
well I'm down on the street I go okay
that's fine let me come to you because
it's my job right so I walked down to
the car because he wants you to cancel
dude he waits I swear to God he waits
till my hand is on the door and he peels
out cancels
really good but now I know Sal is
actually acted as a cab driver I've
never driven a cab yeah on the show you
did was that oh you did how did you feel
about it yeah I I did it twice I think
yeah yeah it was it's kind of crazy you
know because we were messing with them
did you remember Ben Bailey's story no
on Cash Cab no when they weren't he goes
he tells it in his act he said they were
in deadlocked traffic and some guy like
10 cars back kept blaring his horn
and he's like got Furious because he's
like this you know he's like one of
these he's like you your Horn's
doing nothing except irritating right
and he said he got out of the cab and
went back to the guy's car
and was and the guy got out of the car
and he like they almost came to blows
and he said a producer pulled him back
and goes what are you doing Ben you're a
game
I love Batman yeah I haven't seen him in
a while and then the punchline to the
story in his acting goes he goes and
that's when it dawned on me I'm a game
show
[Laughter]
folks I love bread more importantly I
love hero bread oh God why do I love
herobrad well it's soft and it's fluffy
and it's delicious and it's scrumptious
and it's got a wonderful texture and
it's got all the qualities I love about
bread but here's the kicker nutrition
it's also got nutritional value it's
high in fiber it's ultra low in net
carbs and there are zero grams of sugar
per slice also
it has fewer calories than the leading
National brand 5 to 10 grams of protein
per serving I love hero bread it's
everything I like about bread except
even better that's it that's all there
is to it I was eating it all weekend
making sandwiches left and right and
every one of those sandwiches was as
delicious and you know breakfast I do as
a sandwich shop owner I do know I just
got delivered they have sliced breads
they have buns they have tortillas
um I've been eating it this week I
absolutely love it right now Herobrine
is offering our listeners 10 off their
first order just go to hero.co and use
our code taste buds to save on hero
bread today that's hero h e r o dot Co
to save 10 today guys we love game time
on this show and we started using this
app and they are last minute tickets
with the best deals guaranteed I stopped
the way I purchased tickets I use this
app and sometimes now I'll look for
events going on in my you know in my
area like that night which I never
shopped that way before they have
sponsors they have sporting events
Broadway shows everything you think of
playoff games okay killer last minute
deals you get the view from your seat
um a best price guarantee uh game time
takes the guesswork out of buying
tickets
um
you buy tickets in seconds which is two
tabs and what I like about is it gets
sent to your phone so you're not
searching through the email once you get
to the event I love that about it too
and the game time guarantee means you'll
always get the best price if you find
tickets in the same section and row for
Less game time will credit you 110 of
the difference take the guesswork out of
buying tickets with Game Time download
the game time app create an account and
use code taste buds for twenty dollars
off your first purchase term Supply
again create an account redeem code
t-a-s-t-e-b-u-d-s taste buds for twenty
dollars off download game time today
last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed I could not sell after
driving don't you kind of feel for the
because one of the cab drivers I had in
Austin said he gets bed bugs in his cab
once a month that's messed up so I was
in uh was it Austin I was in Nashville I
got in this guy's car right and we're
talking to him and he's like oh yeah man
I'm like you must put up with some crap
you know he's like you don't even know
dude he's like all night drunk all night
drunks and he goes uh he goes
the other day someone threw up all over
my car and I go oh no way and he goes
what'd you do he goes oh and he just
holds up a kit that he has right in the
front and he goes look I got I got
everything he goes I spray it he goes
and I have it ready here and I go you
have it ready how much has it happened
he goes it happens all the time he goes
people throw up my car all the time and
he goes I love it
and I go what he goes I don't care if
they throw up I prefer them to throw up
every time they throw up I get 150
really from Uber yeah I mean it takes a
photo of it and then sends it in and
they give him 150 for the cleanup but he
cleans it up himself but then I'm like
how many people are voted in the car
dude we've had people
we've had people puke in the bar I get I
know how I feel when somebody throws up
in the bar I can't imagine if it was in
my car somebody threw up the other night
and they they like sneak through up
where because we found it after the fact
that we they put their head like down
like this at the bar and peeled on the
floor I think I've done that in my life
and like we have done that in my life it
was disgusting it was just like I've
discussed my life
you see the state of a bathroom you
should see the state of the bathroom in
these In These Bars by the end of a
Saturday night it's like I I don't
understand were you not trained on how
to use an indoor bathroom it's nuts yeah
it's nuts man people are
grossing them because uh this pistol
over the floor and that's gone the
bottom of your shoes and you know you
know the rest I went to a party
I don't even know if he remembers this
Kurt Rhino very funny comic great dude
yeah I went to a party at Kurt
bronholler's house
where he and his wife and his children
live in Los Angeles at their beautiful
home a small party for only colleagues
who are all in their 40s I came out of
his bathroom I go what the is wrong
with everybody sorry sorry no no I just
I go what is wrong with everybody
and uh I'm starting to Jocelyn Hughes
and she goes why what happened I go go
look at the bathroom in there this is a
man's home all of these people are in
their 40s with they're friends of ours
there's piss all over the sink what is
wrong with everybody it's crazy these
are people on TV shows yeah yeah when I
have people over my house when I have a
gathering whatever especially like
friends and especially Comics like like
Super Bowl party or whatever the hell we
do there's always when my I always go on
my half bath and look in there and
there's always piss everywhere you can't
I'm just like guys come on guys you
can't have a Shane Gillis no I'm sure
I'm sure I'm sure Shane has done it I'm
positive he's done in my house you can't
ever I'm trying to think of who I've
seen me and him only left at like four
in the morning he'd definitely pissed on
my stuff shout out to Shane girls that
new special is great by the way yeah
beautiful dogs check it out on Netflix
Oh my God it's so fun so good
um I uh I was in an Uber one time I
forget City I was with one friend and
the guy's driving I wish I wish I could
remember where it was and who it was but
he goes you know as he's driving he goes
you don't mind I just got to make a
quick stop
and I was like in the Uber okay and I'm
like what oh maybe it wasn't an Uber
that maybe it was just a cab but anyway
the cab driver or the Uber driver goes I
gotta make a quick stop he drives we're
in a desolate area that that's like
almost like a industrial area that might
have been natural as well he drives down
a proper alley but it's one of those
alleys where it's like
it's the back of of buildings like um
he drives all the way down at Midway
through
he puts the car in park gets out walks
away through a gate and into an area and
we're sitting in the car running with
the lights on alone in an alley I turned
to my buddy I'm like dude this is not
good right now like this is this is a
setup if I've ever seen one in my entire
life he's like what should we do I'm
like I don't know man just keep an eye
out because if we got out on foot I
didn't even feel comfortable right so I
was like I don't know man you know and
then like two minutes later he came back
out in the car he's like sorry about
that and he kept driving I was like Yo
dude it's insane that he did that yeah I
lived in a we got it all right we'll go
to the voice memos but but I I lived in
a uh it was such a pain in the ass I
lived in a uh really cool complex and
when I lived in La I had this really
cool loft apartment
but it was a big complex with like a
pool and like a gym and in many
buildings and different types of units
and condos and all this stuff
and there were parking garages
underground parking rides and that's how
you access the building in your building
sure
uh and it was always such a pain in the
ass with Uber because you'd get to this
gate you know a lot of times it's 2 A.M
it's a Friday night you're a little
tipsy
and you're like okay so I'm gonna hit
the thing and we're gonna go through
this gate and then you know and a lot of
the time especially female drivers would
be like nah buddy
you're you're getting out here right
which I understood but at the same time
you're like God damn it man I just want
to go yeah but it was you know like
sometimes like stuff like that's a
bummer with constant inconvenience uh
anyway all right so one quick thing
while we're on first of all check out
our merch
we never say it so check it out merch uh
the taste buds uh spray paint one just
sold out and then no matter what happens
I love you just sold out and the socks
are sold out so the only thing that's
left is no matter what happens I love
you hoodie and actually our our
basketball player one sold out too great
so it's no matter what happens I love
you hoodie
or maybe then there's one other thing
available only so great once that goes
we're gonna do a new merch so it's
pretty much gone so check it out new
merch coming and fun we have ideas yeah
good good fun stuff uh the other thing
we never say this but subscribe to no
pressure If you can please uh you know
follow us on Spotify or iTune rate US on
iTunes it helps we never say this stuff
we stop saying it and I think that if we
did every you know every episode you
know it might help so should want to say
that again speaking of Shane click that
like button click that Bell for the
alerts special and speaking of
subscribing uh my my special went on
sale for the Vic oh congratulations
December 2nd in Chicago at the Vic
theater that's great by the time this
comes out it'll have already been on
sale when does this come out Monday
right next Monday well so so guess what
tickets went on sale Friday the 15th
they are on sale right this second at
sabalcanocomedy.com they're gonna go
fast so if they're still available and
you guys see this I'd love to see you in
Chicago it's my debut stand-up comedy
special uh and we price all the tickets
really low so like everyone could come
I'm wondering ring you got support on
this yet I have one person okay yeah
well I'm wondering you were busy well
here's what's crazy I'm on the road the
first
and the third and I got the second open
really so I'm wondering if I can route
it where I fly to Chicago on the second
hang with you for your thing and then
fly man I think I'm in Phoenix on the
first in Salt Lake on the third okay I
don't know if they don't want you to
kill yourself but there will I don't
know if that makes zero shows no friends
coming too and stuff okay let's discuss
yeah so anyway so that's on sale right
now guys
um good and uh yeah I mean it's
interesting and then the other thing is
uh so here's two other things I want to
say one thing I want to do for people
that are coming to this because it's
like the biggest night of my stand-up
career right I'm gonna pick if if you
buy a ticket to any of the shows and you
are there and you all you have to do is
buy a ticket I'm going to pick one
winner out of the show attendees out of
all the show attendees and give them a
plus one I'm gonna fly them to New York
I'm gonna put them up in a hotel and I'm
gonna take them on a set of Impractical
Jokers oh wow that's cool so I I didn't
even announce that yet and so this might
be announced first year but so all you
gotta do if you're coming already great
if you were thinking to come in or you
want to buy a ticket I'm picking one
attendee
I love it that's great man that's great
I'm excited for you thank you and by the
way can we
um
did it announce today no it didn't
announce yet
just say it I don't give a so okay
so another big news other big big first
time ever so I'm gonna be on ship faced
with you yeah Shipwrecked ship face ship
faced with you and and the guys in Eric
Andre I know we wanted to call it Emmy
and Eric Andre fought for this against
everybody and it took like two months of
arguing and we then we relinquished we
wanted to call it
the Impractical Jokers and Eric Andre
take a steaming hot ship
is not ship they didn't want to do it
that is fun uh so I'll be on there with
you for the sole purpose yeah
of doing taste buds live yes first time
ever on the cruise I don't even know if
this is announced yet it probably is and
I might get in trouble but so be it we
want them to know first thing yeah yeah
we're doing taste buds in front of a
live audience for the first time on that
cruise so our audience right now we're
telling you first before it's announced
to everybody else that's coming on that
cruise we're gonna do two live taste
buds together they're gonna be secret
guests a lot of fun
um yeah so I'm so excited that'll be the
first time ever ever doing a live taste
buds ever ever and as of now that's all
I'm scheduled to do on that cruise so
I'm looking at this like
you know coming in oh we're partying
like a vacation yeah I'm like we just
get to do we get to do taste buds and
then just hang out and have fun that's
why the comics love to do it I give them
I give them basically a 15-minute spot a
night that's it it's a vacation this is
awesome so there's a couple of big
Headliners that are going to be
announced too I'm excited um yeah so
that's good um one last thing real quick
okay yeah and then we should go right to
the battle that's right we're getting I
will play these next episodes oh geez we
only have 20 minutes okay we'll play
that next episode okay one other thing I
just want to mention I like to mention
it in because we're always rushing we
want to talk about some but this is kind
of important I started a a YouTube
channel it's called savocano official on
YouTube I'm gonna start loading stuff
onto there stuff from Joker's cutscenes
stand-up Clips all that kind of stuff
commentary and things like that I want
to build it up because I may be putting
some special stuff on there so if you
guys want to subscribe to it what I'm
going to be doing every single week
starting next week once a week I'm going
to pull a subscriber from my YouTube
channel and I'm gonna give away
something a prize each week something
from a video message a proper wardrobe
from the show sign poster free tickets
all stuff like that so every single week
I'm gonna give something a big prize
away and it's only if you're subscribed
so it's at sabalcano official awesome
that's it that's all my plugs I want to
gather I just want to do it in in all
right all right I love it I love it I
love it uh okay we ready to to battle
here let's do it uh we got the the
French fry tourney
first round of the French fry 20 today
we've got classic versus sweet potato
yeah and we've got curly fry versus
crinkle cut uh pimp do we want to time
these
let's say let's put them up yeah split
them into let's say eight eight minutes
for each
let's do it all right let us know when
the clock is going
time two
b-a-t-t-l-e budge okay these are four
different types of fries that are
battling for one win today correct so
first up let's go curly versus crinkle
oh wait then we gotta have the two the
winners face each other yeah so it's
three battles but we do the other one
right away well we'll do another round
of these and eventually the two top
fries will okay yeah so you're taking
crinkle yeah I'm taking curly yeah
crinkle versus curly is the first round
I have my money on curly winning the
entire tournament because there's gonna
be another tournament you're nuts with
steak cut potato wedges but let's focus
on this story well maybe Tater Tot but
let's focus on this right now he's gonna
take the whole thing you're crazy I've
never met one person say that they
didn't love a curly fry curly fries
stink let me tell you why
okay I'll tell you why I was going to
say Well they're great but okay good say
why they're great first of all
in and of itself the curl is the most
fun thing ever it's fun sometimes you
get a full one sometimes you get a half
one but I love the curl I love the
texture I love the feeling it's like the
snake in Qbert just hopping around it's
like a spring that's fun in and of
itself I love how it catches ketchup but
the curly fry seasoning is in and the
way that they batter it and fry it it's
crispy if it's done right and it has a
seasoning like none of the other eight
types of fries and you can't get curly
fries all the time so not only do I
think that the curly fry is the best fry
regardless but the fact that it's not
available all the time makes it even
more special to me because when I see it
on the menu I'm like they got curly
fries awesome
here's why the curly fresh sucks okay
all right uh aside from it nostalgically
reminding me of a fun snake in a video
game I do agree on that uh first of all
here's what happens you do get different
types and sizes and lengths of the curly
fry and what you end up with is two
things you end up with bits of curl that
are way overcooked crunchy dry no uh you
know overcooked and then you end up with
full curls that are wet and mushy in the
middle and crispy on the ends a curly
fry almost never ever is cooked fully
through in the appropriate amount all
the way through maybe not the whole
order some are some but I'm saying I
don't know that I've ever had a full
curly fry where where from front to back
of that one full curly fry it is cooked
properly all the way through there's too
many nooks and crannies in there there's
too many curves and crevices it doesn't
get cooked right it happens it happens
and it does happen where it does get
cooked right but I I won't deny what
you're saying because I I I've seen it
but can I tell you something I don't
mind it well I don't mind the curly ends
and the softer middle I kind of don't
and the curls the curls that are half
curls and stuff and crispy ones that's
my favorite type of here's the other
thing I don't like about a curly fry
it's they're always seasoned with some
weird seasoning I don't know what it is
it's like a weird because it tastes
weird to me curly fries taste like look
there's a couple bites of that sometimes
enjoyable sure absolutely when I was a
kid I'd get excited about curly fries
after four or five I'm like enough with
this flavor man it just tastes like it
tastes like they
no it's it's a it's a it's a it's an
earthy flavor the curly fry has that I
don't care for it's too much I don't
know what that seasoning is it's like a
paprika heavy seasoning pimp what is the
seasoning on curly fries I'm very
curious I have never seen in my life
just a straight up and down
curly fry that was that was the SALT
seasoning and that's it have you yeah
paprika I got it black onion powder and
garlic powder delicious it's too much no
it's not black that's that paprika black
pepper onion powder if that's it God
bless it that's an amazing combination
I'm not Sansa that's a bad combination
but I don't need it on on my fresh it's
too much of my friends say something and
I don't want to get I don't want to get
you know throw a low blow here but and
maybe it will be revealed but you told
me that you were gonna battle when it
was for a waffle fry
a waffle frog that's a different battle
don't pull it into this but I'm just
saying but don't pull it into it it sees
in the same way same way it's not
absolutely it's not no it's not it's the
same thing go to Chick-fil-A get the
waffle fries they are straight up and
down fries but traditionally though a
waffle fry is like a curly fry I have
never I I the the predominant look let's
not Sidetrack we're gonna get we're
gonna get baby ah what is the season of
waffle fry we're gonna paprika okay but
we're not onion garlic okay but hold on
then maybe I won't do it if that's what
that means let's not Sidetrack I'm not
let's not sidetracked let's say I just
said it was weird okay I was talking
about the waffles I've had that or not I
have literally never seen a curly fry
that doesn't have that seasoning on it
right I'm gonna blame Arby's I'm gonna
blame Arby's Arby's that was their thing
the curly fry
they ruined it for me they ruined it for
me now a crinkle cut fry is there
anything more fun is there anything that
takes you more back to 1985 drive-in
movie theater let's walk let's all go to
the movies the crinkle fry if you had to
make a character in a cartoon that was a
french fry you're going with the crinkle
fry it's delicious because I think curly
would be in that too no way dude if you
had to make a quintessential fry
character it is not going to be a curly
well they got it on super Teen Hunger
Force and it's just a classic frog it's
classic but but you notice it crinkle
cut fry it is the exact right thickness
it's a little thicker than traditional
not thickest thick as a steak fry it
adds a crispiness to the outside of that
thing the shape is fun we're having a
good time here the inside is Fluffy
crinkle cut fries are the they're
amazing dude they're amazing you want to
talk fun fries I'm going crinkle cut
every day of the week no
um I'll tell you what critical cut
reminds me of Okay frozen fries orida
crinkle cut in the bag of frozen fries I
grew up on them okay I know I'm very
familiar with the crinkle fry okay and I
really love just like any other fry when
the small pieces get burnt I love a
burnt crinkle fry but for the most part
a crispy one but for the most part I
Gotta Throw That right back on you
my mom used to make them on a on a tray
and bake them right and those two things
one a lot of times they just
were like uncooked in the middle that's
not a fair argument number two that's
not a fair argument because you're
amazing you're talking about baking they
taste bad
they're talking about
you can't use store-bought your mom
baked fries as an argument again I grew
up on them I could make that argument
against any french fry any french fry
you buy in the store from the freezer
section and then go bake at home is
never done right I'm talking about sale
I've seen criminal cut for sale like
less than 10 times in my life oh dude
you're it's always at like some old
Burger shops dude you go to a place and
they got that little cardboard thing of
crinkles of crinkle cut fries this is
different right than what you're saying
no well those are Nathan's is a form of
it that's not what I'm talking about I
know what you're talking about you get
that little cardboard thing dude you you
are I mean my God man it is so fun
crinkle cut fries are the best fries to
make cheese fries out of except for
traditional
um crinkle cut fries are um they feel
cheap and here's here's also why I don't
like that this is what I was gonna say
about the curly fry and the seasoning
and why it's too much the fry is a
respite from the thing you're already
eating it's a side ish if I've got a
burger that has tomato onion pickle on
it may ketchup some mustard whatever it
is you put on your burger a seasoned
Patty of course maybe bacon cheese I'm
eating that and I go I want a little
break from this I want a different
flavor the curly fry is coming in with
too much goddamn flavor that's a crock
of it's not much flavor said no one
ever yeah
I just said it I just said it that's
ridiculous to say that has too much
flavor that's a ridiculous thing it's
over seasoned it's bossy you don't want
your crinkle fries you're putting on
salt pepper and ketchup I'm sure oh so
salty Peppers no pepper salt and ketchup
that's it okay so you're saying and a
little pepper and paprika it Dooms it
it's not a little pepper paprika it's
paprika onion powder which is a pungent
seasoning and garlic powder yeah okay
I ran out of breath I love when you do I
love when you do garlic dude those are
heavy seasonings man oh I'm
telling you delicious though I made
chicken the other night you know you
don't even make chicken you don't need
something and go well this food is
heavily seasoned as well so I'll
probably pass it that's what I'm saying
that's it
that's it your meal needs to be balanced
in flavored listen to me I made chicken
the other night what did I use I'm not
kidding salt pepper onion powder garlic
powder paprika those are my ingredients
you loved it no I I I did I didn't do
the combo right and I was like this
chicken it's too overpowering I had to
take the skin off I'm like the flavor is
too strong but you don't lift up that's
all I think crinkle fries taste I mean
sorry curly fries taste like that a lot
I want a little break I want to dip the
frying ketchup it's too many flavors
going on with the curry and tell me if
you know what at least what I'm I mean
why do I feel that out of every fraud I
feel that the crinkle cut fry is like a
low like it's cheap I feel like it's
like not good potato or something I know
they cut them all from the same potatoes
but like when you bite into a crinkle
cut fry the texture the taste everything
about it feels subpar compared to every
other fry because it's a fun fry and
you're you're just getting fun with
cheap
a crinkle cut fry it's just it's bland
it doesn't take you anywhere
and on that note stop it pimp that's how
this works we went over do we look at
the vote now
sure all right yeah
let's get a drum roll here let's see
what we're saying too let's see what
they're saying let's see what the phones
are saying well we don't have a ton of
time sprinkles okay soggy my sibling in
Christ that's the best part well that's
funny because he called the crinkle
soccer you called the curly soggy and I
said I was okay with the song Rob
Shoemaker says crinkle fresh just mashed
potatoes trying to hide inside a french
fries show that's not true but if it was
that's kind of right why would that ever
be bad why would that ever be bad that
sounds amazing I don't know curly
sprinkle is just too much but curly all
the way how is crinkled too much curly
fries are so good it's like chewing on a
rat's tail people who willingly pick
crinkle cut fries should be never be
trusted curly fries are great for eating
crinkle Verizon best for dipping
The Ridge of the crinkle fry is a handy
tool to keep ketchup applied after
dunking Curly's everyone crinkle make me
think of shitty oven fries from my
childhood
only crinkle fries worth looking at are
Nathan's the curliest soldier legendary
that only one place will make it and
nobody else will dare to attempt it who
what
um
I don't just I don't discriminate but I
love the seasoning that typically goes
on a curly or waffle fry
yeah I get your point but I've only
usually well for us from Chick-fil-A so
they don't they don't put the season
curly fries but I actually have a shot
both of our hairstyles
I mean Curly's gonna win here I hate I
just hate this I used to be curly then I
grew up and realized crinkle is the best
I'll marry crinkle fries and be happy
okay
all right all right all right let's see
I think Crow is gonna win looks like
Curly's uh uh I'm gonna we've got five
thousand votes 5 169 votes at this
second
a wow pimp takes crinkle and curly wins
decisively
67.4 to 32.6 67.4 curly fries that's a
handy win let's move in I do I do
believe though that Curly's gonna win
the whole thing so that didn't surprise
me okay well now we got
classic traditional french fry yeah
versus sweet potato fries this one I
don't know man I think you're gonna take
this one I wonder how far the classic
fry goes because I might be
underestimating the classic fry let's
start the clock and do this a little
different let's start with the phones
okay on this one okay all right so
classic fries sweet potato fries are for
unshaved armpit hippie women
well look here's the thing it's it's a
funny thing to say but I don't see any
truth in that so I don't get the
reference uh like I can't a person named
garlic skin said if you choose sweet
potato fries you shouldn't be allowed to
vote sweet potato sucks that's got to be
derosa's pick for sure oh well wrong
Tammy
traditional
the traditional I'll save it for the
next round I just don't know what shoes
I thought I don't understand what the
difference between shoestring and
traditional are they're just skinnier
literally literally like little little
fries that get really crunchy they like
sticks like basically like four crinkle
fries have you ever had one a shoe
string oh my God where they're my
favorite fries all right all right even
more let's not digress let's not digress
uh taste buds uh spuds that's very good
funny very good whoever chose sweet
potato is a sweet potato and I love you
RXL cherish loves you I choose regular
good salty Fries over my family and
Christ yeah that classic bra may be uh
I'm gonna be underestimating it sweet
potato is better for you but I gotta go
traditional sweet potato fries can go up
my ass into the left all right look
here's my point with sweet potato fries
I can't tell you how many times in my
life
I ordered sweet potato fries or bought
sweet potato fries at the supermarket to
make it home because I thought I was
being healthy one of those times was
when I tried to do McDonald's at home
when I tried to make it healthy every
single time it sucks you're so
disappointed you picked the fry up
you're going to bite it you just
chastised me I know but I'm saying my
mom's version of a crinkle cut I know
but I'm saying I'm saying restaurants
too I'm just saying anytime I've had it
anywhere I'm saying restaurants or at
home but you're talking about when you
made it yeah I know but restaurant I'll
go restaurant too you pick that fry up
you go to bite it no matter how much you
are aware that sweet potato your brain
is going get ready for a french fry and
then you bite it and you go God damn it
and it sucks you know what you say it is
such a bummer you know how you just said
earlier about the the uh you want to
respite from what's going on I mean you
can't check that box more than a sweet
potato fry I can't a traditional fry
what you just said is do you want to
take a fry and you get some but like
this is a departure from the regular fry
it's also a departure from the dish that
you're eating it's right it taste all of
its own and it's another reason when
it's done right it's light it's another
reason I don't like it it's too much of
a of a of a robust flavor in the French
fry that I don't need I need a potato
flavor you're telling me the first time
you ever bitten to a sweet potato fries
oh god dude I didn't go I hate it all I
hated it that's crazy I grew like yams I
grew
baked with the marshmallows and no
that'll make me puke no I like sweet
potatoes I eat sweet potatoes but I like
sweet potatoes as a side with like a
baked sweet potatoes a side with like
but I also prefer the white the Yan the
white
whatever the hell the white one's called
I don't know what that is versus the
orange because the white one is way less
sweet I don't know what you're talking
about I've only known orange there's
like a white sweet potato I think yams
are technically the white one and sweet
potatoes are technically the orange one
there's a difference I don't know anyway
it doesn't matter there's a white sweet
potato that is far less sweet and I like
it a lot better but my point is this I
do like a sweet potato as a side to a
certain type of dish but with a burger
again sweet potato frying ketchup it's
way too much sweet you don't order it
not anymore you never order it no I'm
saying I have many times and I'm
disappointed in me every time so I stop
doing it I I think it is out of out of
the eight types of fries that we named
total which four will be in the next
round the next time sweet potato was the
one outlier that actually is a french
fry but is completely Standalone and
completely uniquely different than the
other seven you can't that's right it's
not even based in C that's where it
sucks it's based in the actual product
but that's why it sucks because you
can't do anything with it you can't do
anything like that's unique and original
and and and you know I've got its own I
could I could say uh oh you know I make
uh I make uh zucchini fries aren't they
great because it's zucchini I'm like no
it sucks here's why it sucks the sweet
potato fry I can't step into any of the
fun Realms that the other frats can step
into you dip a sweet potato frying
ketchup it's too much sugar it's too
sweet it's good it's too sweet you the
seasonings you love on uh on a curly fry
would would taste weird on a sweet
potato to fry uh it's too much of its
own flavor versus the burger and
everything else that you're I hate it I
don't think so because it feels like the
exact texture of a fry completely but
with a little bit of a different taste
they're terrible I think it should be
commended for standing out in a space
that is very redundant
in order classic onion rings a thousand
pounds of duck sweet potato fries
it's money that's really funny shout
outs to just Friday no do you you ever
put malt vinegar on your fries by the
way fudge knows for me that's so gross
my favorite absolute favorite thing to
do with fries yeah that's that Boardwalk
fries crap remember Boardwalk fries you
don't like salt and vinegar chips I love
salt and vinegar strips I hate malt
vinegar and I don't want it on my French
fries and I wouldn't let you know in
vinegar it's a certain no malt vinegar
is a certain type of vinegar I love it
and I don't want vinegar on my French
fries no I don't think it just doesn't
no I love more vinegar man you don't
have fish and chips with more vinegar I
don't like fish and chips I don't
dislike fish and chips I just don't care
about it it doesn't I don't you know
it's a very fish and chips is real milk
toast to me but uh sweet potato for
sweet potatoes but wait a minute wait a
minute
we're we're burying the lead here you
have the the balls you have the balls to
try to pit this against the traditional
french fry the original the one that
started it all I thought if anybody
could take out the original it would be
the one that's the most different from
it you had a better shot with curly
fries versus traditional I have a
feeling curly and classic are going to
meet okay we'll see what happens the
crazy thing is is that they're gonna
meet in this bracket and those I think
are the two big ones we should have put
classical well whatever what are you
gonna do no it's like a one-season
whatever we want we do whatever we want
we'll see what happens that's gonna be a
Pay-Per-View event this is Jesus God
dude you but I'm saying you got the
balls to put this to put this diet fry
by the way people that are like they're
better for you no they're not they're
not as bad they're deep they're not good
why are they not as bad they're deep
fried in oil
oh it depends on how you can bake a
fries I just mean it has a little more
nutritional value but here's what I want
to say maybe more fiber I don't know
because it's less in carbs or something
I don't know yeah I don't get it uh I
lost what I have ADHD and I lost what I
was going to say
fans sweet potato stands as the kids say
people that go hard for sweet potato go
hard like if you're a loyalist you are a
loyal assault a lot of times maybe I was
I have a full sense of uh you know uh
confidence in the sweet potato fry
because a lot of times when I see
someone go and what kind of fries would
you like what do you have we got regular
or sweet potato or whatever else people
always go sweet potato sweet potato they
always just jump on it because they
think it's healthy you never see someone
pass up a sweet potato because they
think it's healthy it's like Diet Coke
but not everybody's like sweet potato
because it's healthy
regular fries all the time sweet
potatoes people hit an age where they go
I'm not allowed to have any fun anymore
let me pretend this dark fate I've
accepted is actually a good time and it
was a choice that's what people are
doing with the sweet potatoes you're
framing it the way I'm framing it that's
what it is I like to have fun I'm gonna
have a sweet potato fry to have fun man
dude you got the traditional fry the
sky's the limit cheese fries fry nachos
but I'm saying you've been doing that
with sweet potato fries let's go to the
phones here no we went to the phones
let's go to the oh are they now are they
facing each other how many minutes are
we in here pimpy we're we're at the end
oh yeah okay all right all right we'll
figure out what fry uh episode maybe
we'll start it early so we get the
winner and put it versus this I I just
wish you'd talk about the technical
aspects of this this tournament a little
bit more on the episode
all right we'll figure it out don't
worry
what was your last story that you told
that you went nowhere the very last
story you told you went oh this is a
parking garage yeah that was a
story
I'd rather talk about the tournament
more than I would like to be honest you
had said something before that where I
tuned out I thought it was relevant and
it wasn't
it's parking garage and then they
wouldn't let me and then it went off
like another four minutes but this I
thought it was relevant to what you said
and I realized it wasn't okay and I
didn't want to say anything all right
pip give us the vote uh we got it 4 100
here on this one
[Laughter]
and so did the rest of Earth
holy cow guys classic I I didn't think
it would be that I I didn't agree with
that big of a margin
this is probably the third second or
third biggest margin in taste plus
history uh 87.5 to 12.5 percent sweet
potato I will tell you though those 12.5
sweet potato people they probably have
tattoos of sweet potatoes the uh that's
crazy dude that's that's crazy I gotta
admit that's nuts I I never and by by
the way by this lot by the logic of
these two percentages I would say
classic is going to take curly if it
goes against it
oh no we shall see I hope people
understand what classic means because
you know people aren't well versed in
the in the cuts they might think classic
is just like not curly or not I'll give
you a perfect example classic sweet
potato they might be think that the
traditional is any fry but sweet potato
I'll give you a perfect example classic
but I'm just saying that margin might
mean that who by the way have never
carried a curly or a sweet potato let me
Point let me put that out there's a
reason for that I hope they didn't think
that it was just regular potatoes not
comprised all of traditional but all
right folks here we go baby we'll be
next oh you know what I still love you I
love you too taste buds they come into
the mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food two fools
two fools coming to them